because of everything that's been going
on in texas this week this tragic
mismanagement combined with denial of
climate science and so many other things
that have led to
millions of people in texas ending up
without power
uh people in austin being told to boil
water which many of them can't do
because they don't have power and
they're relying on either an electric
microwave or an electric
oven and stove that they would need to
boil the water that needs to be boiled
because power is out at the water
treatment plant so this
chaos goes back a long time we know this
because in 2011
similar uh power outages happened in
texas a report was issued explaining
what texas needs to do in order to
protect themselves in situations like
this and they didn't do it
but i want to go back to an interview i
did a few years ago with
gretchen bakke about exactly
the relationship between the electrical
grid
a green alternative renewable energy
the conflicts that exist because of
business interests
and politics and so many other things so
could not be a more relevant time
to revisit this interview with gretchen
let's get right into it i'm joined today
by gretchen bakke who is author of the
grid the fraying
wires between americans and our energy
future
gretchen it's so great to talk to you
know we talk so much about the move
towards alternative and renewable
sources of energy
we talk about the political implications
and and the sort of economic
implications but one thing that's often
missing from that conversation
is sort of the reality of the electrical
grid that we're working with
and some of the limitations that exist
and will sort of have to be dealt with
if we really want to move away from
fossil fuels which i believe that we
should be uh trying to do
let's start as broadly as you want to i
mean what are some of the limitations
that need to be considered
well i think the main thing that people
don't quite grasp when there's when
when when thinking about the energy
transition is that electricity can't
really be stored
right now and what that means is that as
it's made it's used it's this very
instantaneous
um product so as it's made it's used
and that means that if we make it with
something like coal
it's a very steady production and if we
make it with something like wind it's a
very unsteady production
because the amount of electricity
changes as the
as the rate of the wind blowing changes
and so that's called variable generation
and it's the more of it that we
put into our grid um we tend to think of
it as renewables but not all renewables
are variable
and the more we put of it we put into
the grid the
the harder it is to manage this sort of
perfect balancing
of how much electricity we use in any
instant and how much electricity we
produce
in that same instant because electricity
is
essentially instantaneous so almost
never more than a minute between when
it's made and when it's used
and this is particularly relevant for
people who already have or are thinking
of of
moving to solar power in their home
unless you actually have
a means of storing electricity right
unless you have an actual
battery setup any excess electricity
that is harvested by your home solar
system
is not stored for your future use but
rather goes back into the grid and as
you mentioned is almost
instantaneously used by someone else i
mean is that generally the way that it
works
yeah and i think that's one of the
things um that i was really confused
about for a long time was why people
could have diesel generators
um and seem to be like when there was a
blackout they would be able to
power things in their house but if you
have solar panels you can't
um and like many people i thought that
was something that the utilities were on
somehow scheming to make it that you so
you couldn't go off the grid completely
but actually diesel generators have all
these very heavy pieces inside of them
and so
when you turn on a light switch there's
a kind of inertial force
inside the generator that allows it to
balance your house
so the the power you have on or turning
on or turning off at any moment
it has to be balanced by the amount of
electricity that generator is producing
so again the fossil fuel and then this
heavy piece of equipment
enable you to run your house even
without storage
whereas solar panels obviously you're
not going to have any
any power at night um but even so you
turn on your light
there's no way for a sort of for a solar
panel to adjust to that
without some kind of storage so you turn
on a light you're asking for more
electricity from that system but that
system is just producing electricity
based on how much sun is hitting it at
that moment
um and you know we don't use we don't
even think in terms of like
okay it's midday and it's really sunny
so i'm going to run everything right now
right our fridge turns on our freezer
turns on it goes off we turn on the
lights we turn them off
um and all of that has to be balanced in
some way by
something and right now that something
is the grid
and people like the grid it's not
there's not a there's not really a
strong movement i think
against the grid but there is this sense
of like why can't i be energy
independent and the reason for that is
when you turn on a light and you have
solar panels
that extra electricity needs to come
from somewhere so it comes
through the grid um and if the grid is
down
then it doesn't it doesn't come from
anywhere and is part of the path
forward on this i mean elon musk from
tesla has talked about
the home battery systems that they're
working on
that within a few years he says will be
relatively affordable i mean is
is that the type of solution that you
see is the most likely to this problem
i think it's very hard to see the future
because i think that people
really like the idea of being part of
a larger electricity system it's it was
very rare in my research that i found
people that wanted to wanted some kind
of energy
want it to be isolated all the time
they're happy to produce
for the grid um solar panels in
particular like very happy to produce
for the grid during the daytime to
to draw from the grid at night time so i
think
that that there is a possibility
certainly with those home battery
storage systems that you could be energy
independent all the time so you wouldn't
need the grid at all
um but i think what's more likely is
that people will start to use those so
that
they have power when the power is out on
the larger system
um and and that was a lot of what was
happening when i was doing my research
is that a lot of the frustration i found
with the electricity system part of it
was this feeling of like we want more
renewables
which is which is very hard to manage
and i think there's a lot of work going
in that direction
by people who do manage the grid right
now but not fast enough
right there's uh there's a lot of anger
with the utilities in particular for not
making that transition quickly enough um
but the other big frustration
was my power's out all the time i have
solar panels
why can't i just have my power be on
like
why do i have to also have a diesel
backup generator um so
this movement from from producing power
independently but also
trying to be green at home and wanting
the larger electricity system to be
green as well
so if we step aside a little bit from
the storage aspect of it i'd love to
talk a little bit about some of the
other ways in which the grid
is relatively susceptible to outside
forces i mean
we have mostly in this country elevated
power lines where
anything from weather to a squirrel can
cause pretty significant
interruptions is that one of the biggest
sort of liabilities
in the american electrical grid right
now
um you mean the the power lines being
above ground yeah
certainly certainly it's uh it is in
part because the greatest threat to the
grid right now is growing trees
so if they were underground that would
be less of a problem it's really hard to
cut back
all of the foliage that is just up and
coming over this huge nation right it's
always just going up and up and up and
sort of grabbing at power lines
so yes it's not always the answer to
barry though if you have some place like
florida with a high
um a sort of a high title
i don't know i think the word is scale
but the water comes up very high tidally
or when when it's very wet you don't
want to bury um you don't want to bury
lines and you don't even want
um critical infrastructure at ground
level you want to start putting stuff up
you want to put your substations on
hills
um so for some places it's quite it's
quite a good idea to bury lines
in other places it's a less good idea
the grid is weirdly
local so we have three of them in the
u.s and they're each gigantic they're
these huge machines are sort of one for
the west one for the east and one for
texas
but nevertheless it's also extremely
local in how it's designed how different
states have
been keeping it up the kinds of laws
there are laws that are federal but
there are many laws that are very
um particular to states or even to
counties or to municipalities
um so taking into account the weather in
particular places matters
for answering that question um but it's
also extremely expensive to bury lines
yeah and that also gets towards what's
sort of underlying this which is
i don't know if i would call it a
jurisdictional issue but certainly one
of ownership which is that
there's not like a single entity that
owns or controls or maintains
the grid right i mean as you're sort of
talking about you're talking about
municipalities and a lot of smaller
entities that are part of this grid
and even manage their own grid there are
many municipal like
los angeles for example has it manages
its own
grid even though that grid is connected
into the entire
gigantic grid which covers the whole of
the west it's still that particular
piece of it like
where they're buying electricity from
how much they're paying for it
who's maintaining the lines um all of
that is is managed by the municipality
and
some municipal grids are very very small
i i talk about in the book rancho
cucamonga which has one streetlight but
they have a municipal
power um municipal power governance
um and people again are sort of
organizing suburbs etc as they get
frustrated with the
the rate of change um
to a more renewable renewably powered
system they are they'll they'll just get
towns or suburbs together and they'll
they'll disaggregate it's called from
the big grid and take over their own
little
um piece of it to manage it for
themselves um so that's sort of that's a
that happens legally in the states so
it's both big and
you know very very small very very local
um and absolutely you know nationally
gigantic
and i think that's where you see a lot
of the excitement about what's happening
right now i know most people don't
really see the grid or think about the
grid but it's
it's changing radically at this exact
moment in time
and lots of people are causing that
change to happen in different ways
well it is a hugely important issue
particularly when we have the
conversation about
when and how will we get off of fossil
fuels it's something that that could not
be more important again we've been
talking about the book the grid
the fraying wires between americans and
our energy future
and we've been speaking with the book's
author gretchen bakke thanks so much for
talking to us about this
yeah my pleasure thank you